hey guys Pete here it's gonna be my
recap and review for the rewatch of
season 1 Twin Peaks we're gonna look at
two which is the third episode of the
season the episode is also known as Zen
or the skill to catch a killer
and at first aired on television on
April 19 1996 co-creators David Lynch
and Mark Frost both this is the third
episode in a row that they both wrote
together and this one is the second one
that David Lynch directed and probably
one of the most famous episodes of the
entire series based on the red-room
sequence in Cooper's dream at the end
the log lady intro that they added to
this in 93 is sometimes ideas like men
jump up and say hello they introduce
themselves these ideas with words are
they words these ideas speak so
strangely all that we see in this world
is based on someone's ideas some ideas
are destructive some are constructive
some ideas can arrive in the form of a
dream I can say it again some ideas
arrive in the form of a dream so the
episode opens up in a different way we
see that the horn family is eating
dinner at the table and we see the
credits sort of continue to roll over
that as they eat in silence jerry horn
makes his first big appearance he's been
in the show before but this was his
first big scene I would say and we get
this really strange food fascination
scene I don't know what else to call it
I mean there's sort of a lot of that in
this series if you think about it I mean
you've got Cooper's love of coffee
cherry pie you've got the scene right
here and the way these to eat these brie
sandwiches is pretty enthusiastic at
least I would say but after they have
their baguettes with brie and butter Ben
and Jerry go outside of the room and he
tells them about what happened with the
Norwegians and Jerry mentions that he's
depressed
Ben mentions that he can fix that
a new girl at one-eyed Jack's they hop
in a boat and they go there to Canada
the border and we get introduced to both
one-eyed Jack's and Blackie the madam
who runs the place
it's a pretty racy scene I would think
given the context of the time at first
aired the lingerie is pretty exciting
and sort of the hallway that the way
that it's set up I mean it's just kind
of like pretty over the top for regular
Network TV at that time I would sink
other than that not much happens we see
the bends just kind of creepy and that
Jerry is a sidekick ish sort of
character and get a little bit of
intrigue with Blackie but we don't get a
whole lot going on there at that time we
go over and pick up with Donna and James
over at the Hayward house they're
finishing dinner and then they have some
time alone and I've mentioned it in
previous videos you know this is the
part that kind of is the least exciting
or interesting to me and yeah you know
they go through the same thing again
there they feel like they're betraying
Laura and not much else happens we see
that they're falling in love but they
have these conflicted feelings see agent
Cooper go back to his room he blows a
dock call which is inexplicable I don't
know how that fits into anything else he
gets a phone call from deputy Hawk who
explains to him that ronette is still in
the coma and he found out that she
worked at the perfume counter at Ben
Horne's store so when you go back and
watch this now all these things sort of
fit into place a little bit you know on
first watch you don't really get a whole
lot of the connection here but one of
the things I realized about this is that
it is pretty the word be the timeline is
pretty consistent early on and but
either way Hawk tells him that he saw
one armed man which will turn out to be
interesting later and as he's getting
off the phone he hears someone knock at
the door but when he goes there's no one
there but there's a note that says jack
with one eye we see Bobby and Mike go to
pick up some drugs and we see that Leo's
waiting there too
scare them we already knew that they
didn't have the money because of what
happened with the safety deposit box so
this just establishes that they have a
serious situation going on they need to
figure out a way to pay them back I
always liked the big flashlight scenes
the whatever I don't know what the
technical term for that kind of
flashlight is but I always like the way
those looked so that was pretty cool
when they're walking up but again not
much here other than leo is a bad dude
and these two kids are in over their
head basically there's also a hint that
Leo is upset with Shelly which we knew
and Bobby I think pretty much craps his
pants because he's this guy who has a
shotgun knows that he's cheating with
his wife but at this point there doesn't
seem to be any indication of that it's
just he knows she's doing something
wrong and we saw him give her that soap
bar in the sock treatment in the last
episode get our first really great
Nadine scene I think here I really like
the way that this character is portrayed
I mean it's like it's one of those
things like the character if you
described it to me it sounds silly but I
just think that I just think that Wendy
Roby does such a good job of being
Nadine Hurley like she's a good actress
and Edie is also obviously really great
and we get this funny scene where he
comes in we don't know why he's covered
in grease but he's trying to be very
careful and he ends up standing stepping
on her curtain rods and we see her flip
out break the rowing machine in this
hope you know meltdown kind of thing
going on there's a quick shot of Bobby
going to Shelly at her house and it's
kind of out of place when you think
about it but basically the bottom line
of that part is that he sees that Leo
gave her the bruises and he's really
upset about it but I guess you know we
find out that it's not just the fling he
does really care for her you know in
that exchange so it's a little bit of
confusion when you think about it
because Laura supposed to be Bobby's
girlfriend but we find out that his true
feelings are definitely with Shelly let
me get one of my favorite set up kind of
scenes and we get a insight into agent
Cooper and his
technique the old bottle on the log
thing that comes from the dream it's
funny to watch them setting it up you
know nobody knows what he's doing or why
he's doing it
and you just kind of think about like we
know these characters so we it's been
established to us how it is but just
imagine a small town police department
and they have this fancy FBI guy coming
in and they're sitting there with table
full doughnuts and he's told him to set
up this bottle at a certain place with
the you know I mean it's just it's just
a really I really enjoy the scene for
some reason he does talk about his dream
three years prior about the plight of
the Tibetan people and how he and my you
know he came out of it with this
subconsciously gained knowledge of a
deductive technique involving mind body
coordination working hand in hand with
the deepest levels of intuition to quote
so everything that we thought we knew
about Cooper so far is just being
amplified through this scene but it is
interesting thinking about it going you
know watching it now after season 3 and
the final dossier you know the fact that
this episode ends with his dream and
just how much all of what Cooper did had
to do with dreams in a way you know what
I mean
but they basically what happens is is
they they're gonna go through the Jays
because of that note in Laura's diary
about nervous about seeing Jay
he throws rocks at a bottle as sheriff
Truman tells us all the different Jay
people's connection to Laura he hits the
bottle for dr. Jacoby but it doesn't
break it falls off and then when he does
it again for Leo he actually does break
the bottle which puts Leo on top of the
suspect list the next scene is the
iconic Audrey's dance scene and it's
definitely a classic we get the feeling
here from the Hayward's that Audrey's an
odd girl and that they really don't know
what to make of her when Donna comes
over that's just furthered in the way
that she behaves she talks about agent
Cooper love and coffee and the whole
nine yards and you know just sort of
goes on about that and then there's a
strange moment whenever Audrey asked
Donna if Laura ever talked about her
father but before they really get into
it then Audrey gets up and dances and
yeah that was sort of the scene that
defines the Audrey character I think
another great introduction happens right
after that when Albert Rosenfeld enters
the Twin Peaks Sheriff's Department and
we get an idea of what his character is
all about Albert's a giant jerk of
course when he comes in
Truman puts up with it but he gives him
a stern warning we got a bunch of other
stuff that happens pretty quickly ed
makes his way out of the doghouse
because that grease that he dropped
actually was the key to Nadine invention
so she's really excited we get an idea
about Katharine and Pete's marriage and
how that goes and we see that he passes
a key to Josie who goes and finds that
there's two Ledger's instead of one in
the safe which is proof that Katherine's
up to something she's cooking the book
so that one looks like they have a
healthy prop that the other one looks
like they're bankrupt then we get our
first really haunting leyland scene
where he starts playing a record he
starts dancing with the picture we see
Sarah come in she freaks out they
struggle over it the picture breaks kind
of cuts his hand and he's like it's a
pathetic display we see that there that
he's a very troubled character here and
that we see Sarah scream what's going on
in this house and in retrospect that
kind of gives you an idea that maybe
there is something going on in that
house and then we get to the big finale
the big important part of this episode
in an episode that a lot of stuff
happened really when you think but this
may be the most important part of the
entire series and that is aja Cooper's
dream starts out with him going to bed
and then we see him in a room where he's
made up to look like he's older and the
first really haunting lodge image is the
little man from another place as he's
turned around backwards and he's sort of
shaking and we can see that something
very strange is happening here in this
area
there's a couple quick flashes we see
Sarah Palmer run down the stairs we see
the guy that we find out is
named Bob and we get a shot of the
murder scene then the one-armed man
comes back into the picture and he
introduces himself to coop and it
doesn't necessarily make sense when you
first hear it and maybe never but he you
know he says through the darkness of
Future past and the magician longs to
see one chance out between two worlds
fire walk with me he explains his name's
Mike and that he used to kick it with
Bob above what we would call a
convenience store they killed together
Mike the one-armed man says that he saw
the face of God and he stopped the
killing by taking off his own arm then
we see Bob and he says that he catch you
with his death bag then he goes on to
say you may think I've gone insane but I
promise I will kill again
back in the Red Room Cooper is sitting
across from the two chairs and in one
now sits Laura Palmer the dwarf is in
the other and he says let's rock and you
already know this but I'm gonna say it
anyway it's just because obviously when
they talk they're saying the words
backwards it's recorded and then
reversed so that it has this really
strange thing in its caption which is
very bizarre the first time you see I
mean it's bizarre all the time but it's
especially bizarre the first time you
see it because you really don't know
what's happening he tells Cooper that
he's got good news that gum you likes
coming back in style he mentions that
Laura's his cousin and that she's filled
with secrets Cooper asked directly to
her if she is Laura and she responds I
feel like I know her but sometimes my
arms Bend back the man from another
place goes on to say where we're from
the birds sing a pretty song and there's
always music in the air and this is
where that jazz music sort of kicks in
he gets up he starts to dance Laura
comes over gives Cooper a kiss and then
whisper something in his ear coupe wakes
up with some serious bad hair
he calls sheriff Truman tells him to
come to the hotel to meet him for
breakfast because he knows who killed
Laura Palmer
then he says yes it can wait till
morning so even though a lot of stuff
happens in this episode really this is
what it all boils down to is this short
dream sequence
what's always been fascinating to me
whenever I started to learn more about
the series though is that we know that a
lot of this footage is recycled from the
alternate ending of the pilot and it
really just kind of makes you wonder how
much of this did they actually have like
how much of the Black Lodge the waiting
room all this stuff was actually really
thought about ahead of time I mean these
became cornerstone parts of the story
but if you think about what the log lady
says in the beginning about ideas
jumping out and the fact that the legend
is that David Lynch says he came up with
the whole Red Room sequence by touching
the hood of a car when the engine was
still on and the entire thing came to
him in a flash it just makes you wonder
if there was really any strong sense
that these would be some of the
mysteries that would be enduring I mean
obviously there's supposed to be
mysterious but based on everything that
we've seen after the fact and the way
that this all developed it's just it's
just kind of crazy to think about it in
that way so yeah it comes from a longer
sequence and basically the way that the
international pilot is what's referred
to now is called because they've made
this as like a standalone movie in for
the European market and it really there
was no way to do it you know what I mean
so they sort of came up with this idea
that mrs. Palmer Sarah Palmer saw Bob
but forgot and then they find him in the
basement of the hospital and then just
added all the red-room stuff at least
that's the way I understand it and I
mean that's the way when you watch it it
is it's just it's just there you know
what I mean it doesn't really explain
much so an interesting fact about it is
though for a long time you couldn't see
the real pilot that the one that we
watched now or the one that aired on the
VHS release so the way that it ended was
like totally contradictory to the rest
of the series we do see invitation to
love for the first time Shelley is
watching at her house when Bobby shows
up that is a recurring theme throughout
the first season
another thing that is reported is that
whenever ray wise leland is rubbing the
blood that's his real blood
he accidentally cut his hand and he sort
of improvised that part of the scene and
like I mentioned the big thing here is
the first introduction of the arm the
man from another place I wish I could
honestly say that I remember how I
reacted to this when I first watched it
I remember thinking that it was weird
I don't remember trying to solve a
mystery about it because I remember a
little bit probably about five or six
years ago a friend of mine was watching
it for the first time and they were like
that dream it was a it was a dream
though you know and I think probably
that was probably the same way that I
thought about it too was that it was
just a creepy dream that he had and that
there may be something important in
there but we would find out naturally as
things went on it didn't dawn on me I
don't think at the time that this would
be something that we would talk about
for decades to come so it's a great
episode like I said I really like the
emergence of the FBI and the
contradiction between the FBI and the
small-town Sheriff's Department pretty
sure this is when I decided that Ben
Horne was just creepy and I didn't enjoy
his character I mean I enjoy it watching
him but he's just not a good person
Audrey obviously set up her place as
being a very captivating character
throughout and James and Donna just
started to get on my nerves and I think
a little bit with Mike and Bobby too
because of they're not bad characters
it's just they're playing high school
jocks who sell drugs and you know what I
mean like they're not likable but I do
think that on the rewatch I realized a
little bit more about how that whole
exchange was Shelley and Bobby how there
was something real there in how he
wanted to protect her from leo so that's
all I'm gonna say about this right now
we'll definitely talk more about the red
and all of that as this goes on it's one
of my favorite episodes still although I
think that the first three really
together is the genesis you know what I
mean like I don't know that this stands
out
obviously the pilot is good in a
different way the second episode sets a
lot of things up and then this one takes
us in a different direction so it would
be really hard to say that one of these
would stand out as essential I mean as a
trio they're really all pretty essential
as far as I'm concerned so let me know
what you guys think in the comments
thanks to my patreon patrons for making
this happen sorry this took a little bit
longer but I'll be continuing on with
the rest of the season think about
joining us over there I've been really
the I've been really obsessed with the
final dossier and just thinking about
that and I want to make some more videos
about that as well but I will this is
what you guys voted on and this is what
I will so make sure you subscribe if you
haven't already make sure you turn on
notifications after you do that follow
me on Twitter and my other social media
accounts thanks for watching guys I'll
talk to you soon